dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here this is a
follow-up work to a technique we have
talked about earlier we have seen how
different creatures learn to walk and
their movement patterns happen to be
robust to slight variations in the
terrain in this work we imagine these
creatures as a collection of drawings
and links typically around 20 links
depending on what actions we choose for
these individual body parts in time we
can construct movements such as walking
or leaping forward however this time
these creatures not only learn to walk
but they also monitor their surroundings
and are also taught to cope with immense
difficulties that arise from larger
terrain differences this means that they
learn both on character features like
where the center of mass is and what the
velocity of different body parts are and
terrain features such as what the
displacement of the slope we are walking
up on is or if there's a wall ahead of
us
the used machinery to achieve this is
deep reinforcement learning it is
therefore a combination of a deep neural
network and a reinforcement learning
algorithm the neural network learns the
correspondence between these states and
output actions and the reinforcement
learner tries to guess which action will
lead to a positive reward which is
typically measured as our progress on
how far we got through the level in this
footage we can witness how a simple
learning algorithm built from these two
puzzle pieces can teach these creatures
to modify their center of mass and adapt
their movement to overcome more
sophisticated obstacles and other kinds
of adversities
and please note that the technique still
supports a variety of different creature
setups one important limitation of this
technique is that it is restricted to 2d
this means that the characters can walk
around noting a 3d world but on a plane
a question whether we are shackled by
the 2d Ness of the technique or if the
results can be applied to 3d remains to
be seen
I'd like to note that candidly
discussing limitations is immensely
important in research and the most
important thing is often not what we can
do at this moment but the long term
potential of the technique which I think
this work has in abundance it's very
clear that in this research area and
normal sleeves are made year by year and
there is lots to be excited about as
more papers are published on this
locomotion problem the authors also
discussed that it would be great to have
a unified physic system and some error
metrics so that we can measure these
techniques against each other on equal
footings I feel that such a work would
provide fertile grounds for more
exploration in this area and if I see
more papers akin to this one I'll be a
happy man thanks for watching and for
your generous support and I'll see you
next time